- That's my fuckin' favorite by the way.
If you're a fuckin' 22-year-old life coach
get the fuck out of here right now!
♪ Hey. ♪
You got your perspective.
(upbeat techno music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(blues organ music)
(speaking off mic)
- [Male] He's gonna be doing
a special master class in February
so make sure you take out your phone.
Make sure you take out your phone,
take a picture of this slide
and go to that website,
majorfadementor-mastersclass.com.au,
mentor-masterclass.com.au.
It's the first time
that he's gonna be doing
an event like this.
You can see him in Perth on February 21st,
Melbourne February 25th,
and Sydney on February 27th.
Make sure you get a picture of that,
make sure you go online.
There's a special offer for
you all for being at success
squared, mentor-masterclass.com.au.
Alright Sydney, give yourselves a hand
for making it through today so far.
(crowd applauding)
I encourage everybody to please stand up.
Please stand up.
The moment we've all been
waiting for is finally here.
But we need everyone to
sky rocket extremely high,
put both hands in the air,
both hands in the air,
on the count of three Syndey right there
(speaking off mic) one two three.
(crown yells)
(speaking off mic)
One, two, three.
- [Crowd] Yes.
(speaking off mic)
Stay standing for (speaking off mic).
Serial entrepreneur, a CEO,
co-founder of VaynerMedia
a full service digital
company servicing Fortune 500
clients through out the
company's 4 locations.
Gary rose to prominence
in the late '90s after
establishing one of
the first key owners of
Wine Library, helped his father grow the
family business from four
to $60 million in sales.
Gary is also one of the
most sought after public
speakers alive today.
He's a venture capitalist,
four time New York times
best selling author and
(speaking off mic) companies
such as Square, Health
Alert, Venmo and Uber,
Gary's big (speaking off mic)
- [Male] So Syndey if you
could, give mad mad love
to Gary Vaynerchuk.
(crowd cheers)
(rap music)
- [Gary] What up?
(cheering)
Thank you, thank you, what up?
You can sit, thank you.
What up Sydney?
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Thank you.
Big shout out to everybody
in the fuckin' back .
(cheering)
The best part about doin'
that is it takes like
2 minutes for the sound
to get up here (laughter).
Super excited to be
here thank you so much.
Lot to cover this afternoon,
lookin' forward to
the Q&A that we have but
really just wanted to start
with a couple of key
pillars really around the
opportunity at hand.
For me the thing that's
really in my mind constantly
over the last three to four
months is that literally everything
that's about to come out of my mouth
the biggest religions that I have
around business and being a human
just literally everything that I believe
wasn't possible for our grandparents.
This Internet thing and
we'll get into social
and tactics and a million
other things but this
internet thing is fucking enormous.
It's much bigger than everybody
in this conference hall
realizes including the
guy that's delivering
this speech right now and the truth is
it's in a sweet spot.
If you look at real estate, if you look at
the printing press, if
you look at the invention
of television or when people
explore new territories
countries opportunities,
those moments are really
interesting 'cause they
all take very different
timelines and you've got
people who get a lot of upside
in the very beginning but
there's a lot of casualties.
I mean like literally
discovering a new land,
literally landing on a new land,
there's people that have
to taste weird berries
and some of those fuckers died
because they're poisonous.
(laughter)
And so like there's risk in the beginning.
I launched an e-commerce,
it's so funny right now
as a lot of you know because
of Shopify and Instagram
and other things, e-commerce selling stuff
especially for influencers
who are now getting
into merchandise is
becoming like this thing.
And everyone's like oh
e-commerce, and I literally
think to myself my God
I launched an e-commerce
wine business in 1996 when
a lot of these influencers
weren't even born yet so
I've been through the early
stages of the opportunity
of the internet but this
moment, late 2018 what
excites me especially in
the context of me having to give a speech
is regardless of where
you are in your career,
how much money you make,
how much ambition you have
how old you are, what you do,
do you work for somebody, do you not,
are you in school, no matter
what the circumstances
for everybody in this event,
the one thing that we are all
completely bound by are
two things that continue
to run through my head.
Number one, attention.
The one thing that
everybody here has to amass
is the other person's attention.
Regardless of your ambition here,
whether it's to build a
business, to run for political
office, to raise money for a
nonprofit, the one thing that
is guaranteed, how many people
here are in B2B businesses?
Raise your hand, just
raise 'em high, right.
And B2C?
And how many people by show of hands here
work for a company, raise your hands.
Great, so regardless of there's three very
very different hand raises,
attention is the one
thing that we are all bound by
because we all need it to
achieve whatever we want.
The other thing we're
all completely tied to
regardless of our circumstance right now
is our timing, we're
all here right now here.
And let me tell you
about here and right now.
For all the things that
people are cynical about
and shitting on for the internet,
the fact that people think social media
leads to all these negativities,
bullying and other all these things,
regardless of how you look at it
the flip side is remarkably true.
The opportunity to do what you want to do
and be happy is far greater
in an Internet world
where the Internet is the
middleman, not an actual
human being or a company.
We are living through a
time where literally this
is the game and to me that is remarkable
because it's completely
democratized our opportunity.
The biggest reason most
people in this auditorium
tonight are not winning
to where they want to be
is far more on themselves
than on the outside forces.
The reason I'm remarkably
happy as a human being
is because my favorite word
and the framework of my life
and how I navigate it is accountability.
I'm stunned by the fact that most people
haven't wrapped their head around the fact
that accountability is what
actually leads to happiness.
I am also stunned that
people still think that money
is a parallel to happiness.
You know, if I could
achieve anything tonight
it would be putting people
in a place of understanding
that the far majority of this room
would be much happier
making $100,000 a year
then making $1,000,000 a year.
It doesn't make sense when
you're not in either place
but it's remarkable to
watch the world navigate.
And as we start getting
into far more interesting
territories as humans around
mental health and other things
of that nature, I think we are
on the early stages of having
far more mature conversations
about what the fuck are we
doing on this planet and what
actually puts us in a good
place and I really genuinely
believe that this is a
remarkable time.
I mean, I think for me as you can imagine
when I stand up here there
really is only one ROI
for me, actually there's
two, one I waanna put
things on film that are
historically correct.
The reason I talk about everybody here
buying Facebook ads and Instagram ads
and creating content at
scale and doing podcasts
and influencer marketing and all of that
detailed stuff the reason
I put it out selfishly
is 'cause it's all gonna be looked upon
five to ten years from
now as an underpriced
execution during this era.
Amazon, a company I'm
completely fascinated by
was the biggest spender on Google
in the first five to seven
years of that platform,
they used those ads that
were underpriced 'till it
become one of the biggest
companies in the world.
I am able to have 3,500
people come to a conference
in Australia on the other
side of the world on the back
of executing on YouTube
and Facebook and Instagram
properly, it's not super
complicated, the concept's
not complicated.
I often refer to the concept similar to
being in good shape,
like being in good shape
is super basic, eat well and
exercise dick face, right?
(laughter)
The problem isn't the
thesis, the strategy is not
the problem, the problem is
cupcakes are fuckin' delicious.
(laughter)
Right, so to me it's no
different than what I think
about everybody should be
doing here for their business
or the way they should be marketing.
I can sit here and I've pounded it.
How many people here consume
my content on the Internet?
Raise your hands, cool.
(cheering)
I've pounded the thesis down your throat
over the last two years
at scale, in fuckin'
video form, in picture
form, in written form,
in audio form, like I'm
tryin' to like you know,
I'm tryin' to create
new ways to be in forums
to say the same fuckin' shit which is
which is (laughter), got a
little closer there buddy.
Which is, which is very
simply this is what holds
the attention of our
society and I'm sure there's
people out sitting in
this audience that say
their customers aren't on it or their age
group isn't on it, but
the data's very clear
that between Facebook
and LinkedIn and YouTube
you are going to be able to reach,
and by the way one of the
remarkable things of coming
to this amazing country is that my thesis
on what's happening is
actually a better deal
in Australia than it is in the US
'cause in the US some
companies are starting
to figure it out which
makes the prices go up.
The prices are remarkably underpriced,
I mean literally I don't
care if you're a lawyer
a financial advisor, a
real estate executive,
a fitness influencer, you sell jump ropes,
candy I don't give a shit,
if you are not running ads
on Facebook and Instagram
at scale, you're making a huge mistake.
And please understand that
I know many of you have run
ads and they didn't work
and it's because the ads
the videos and the
pictures were your problem,
or the way that you segmented the media.
There is no debate that the media itself
is underpriced but you
have to know how to use it.
And so for me it's just a remarkable time.
Obviously if you follow me on Instagram
a place where I only have
one minute to make a video
I've been much more into
mindset and strategy
on that platform and that's another place
that I spend a lot of time on.
In a world where I know the
far majority of this room
knows where I stand or
what to do on social media
to drive their business or their ambition,
it's remarkable that so
many of you don't do it.
After schpeiling every day
for years, I came to realize
it's not about the education,
it's about where they
are here that is clearly
dictating why they're not
doing it.
That started getting me
into places around judgment
and insecurities they
way people were raised,
just a million different
variables and I stand here
today excited because
I also believe for all
the negative, obviously as the world
has become highly
political with all the way
the people manifest the
thing that I believe in
the most misery loves
company, so watching people
actually, I mean guys,
it is remarkable for me
to watch people actually spend their time
to go on somebody else's
profile and say something
shitty about them.
Like how many people here
have had somebody comment
shitty about them on a post
on social, raise your hand.
Cool.
I just wanna really put
this seed in your mind
as somebody who gets thousands
of shitty comments about him
on a daily basis (laughter).
If somebody actually
has the time to consume
your content, and then leave
something shitty about you
with their time think
about how fucked up their
life actually is.
(laughter)
I have never to this day felt bad for me
when somebody leaves a shitty comment.
I literally look at it
and I feel bad for them
because I never in a million years because
of all the happiness
that I have inside of me
would waste two seconds
saying something bad
about somebody for no reason.
And more importantly
and probably the thing
that I need to spend a lot more time on
is the word that drives my
life is actually context,
not content.
I talked so much about content.
The reason I am successful at what I do
and my companies are successful
and the companies I buy are successful
and the people to follow are successful
is 'cause they're great at
context, not just content.
Clearly if you don't have
context on the other person,
if you're not deploying
empathy for the other person,
if you're not worried about them,
that you have no shot.
It's really no different
than giving a speech.
The reason I'm a dominant public speaker
and one of the best at what I do
is because I'm far more
worried in the next 32 minutes
plus about delivering you
value and giving stuff for you
not what I can get out of it for me.
You know some speakers get confused
and they want your money, I
don't want your fuckin' money.
I want you to win and
then send me an email
that you fuckin' won, understand?
(cheering)
'Cause I don't need your
fuckin' money 'cause I know
how to make money sellin'
shit I find at garage sales.
(laughter)
(laughs) That's a whole nother
keynote for another day,
I'm so fucked.
I'm about to lose my mind,
you're about to lose me
into a very deep seed of
garage selling and flipping
on eBay, so I'll miss all of you.
This might be my last fuckin' speech.
(laughter)
My friends, this is a
remarkably special time
and I'm completely
convinced the far majority,
and I mean 99% of this
room is going to regret it.
I'm completely convinced about it.
It's not fun for me to say that
but it's very obvious to me that humans
take shit for granted and are really
bad at perspective and timing.
The reason I push patience,
how many people here are under 30?
Raise your hands, stand
up if you're under 30.
Don't be a dick, stand up.
(laughter)
Let's first of all clap it
up for all the youngsters
in the room (cheering) (applause).
Keep standing, you're
young, you're not tired yet.
(laughter)
If you're standing right
now, you really have,
like let's get into perspective
and actual understanding.
If you're standing right
now, with the way that
modern medicine is actually
evolving, there is a very
high percentage that you're
gonna live three more
lives that you're already
lived if not five.
Like do you understand why I struggle when
people give up on shit a year or two in
or upset that they
haven't gotten there yet,
three years in when you
fuck faces are about to live
four more lives?
(laughter)
I'm being serious, like you're literally
gonna live four more lives, five more,
like from the day you
were born that you can not
fuckin' remember 'till right this second,
you're about to do that
three to four more times.
You can sit, literally your
biggest advantage is timing.
For all of the great things
that I have in my life
I would literally give it
up, all of it, all of it
just to be 25.
I would give up for 17 years
I'd give up everything I have
'cause that's how valuable
time is in the far majority
of this room has time, time as their asset
and every day the number
one asset they have time
they give away by being inpatient,
mainly on the back of listening to society
or their parents that they
have to have their shit
figured out at this age.
The fact that people actually
think at 18, 22, or 30
you have to have your shit
figured out is fuckin' ridiculous.
Let me promise you all
those parents and uncles
and grandparents that
push down your throat
that you have to figure it out by now
they still haven't
figured it the fuck out.
(applause)
I mean it.
So this nonsense, this
fuckin' nonsense that you have
to have it figured out
at 18, 22, 30, you know
how many people freak the fuck out at 30?
How many people are 30 right now?
That shit was crazy, right?
Like people lose their shit at 30.
Like meanwhile, they're a fuckin' kid.
And so I'm unbelievably aware lately
that one of the, you
know people who's like
why do you win, and I
talked about my parents
and not coming from anything,
but the more that I live
I'm like shit, the reason
I really win is 'cause
I understand time.
And listen, I know I can
get hit by a bus or get
terminally ill, I get it.
Here's the problem,
that's far more unlikely
for the majority of us.
The math works in your favor.
And we are stunningly not patient.
Patience has been the
foundation of my succ...
Patience, adversity,
these are the foundations
of my success.
How many people under 28 raise your hands.
The majority, half this room, guys, gals,
at 28 years old, I was in the basement
of a liquor store packing
wine in a box to ship.
That's what I was doing
for my career, 20 years.
I was making $67,000 a year
packing wine shipping it out.
I was the help, I was in a warehouse.
Everybody now has to be
like a fuckin' entrepreneur
like life coach at 22 years old.
That's my fuckin' favorite by the way.
If you're a fuckin' 22
year old life coach,
get the fuck out of here right now.
(laughter)
(applause)
Get the fuck out.
I'm gonna pay you 5,000 a
month to tell me how to live.
You fuckin' idiot.
(laughter)
Fuck you.
(laughter).
Stupid.
That's the thing, by the
way, it works both ways.
Parents, I love parents who shit on,
I'm so tired of people
shitting on millennials.
You know who shits on millennials?
The fuckers that fuckin' parented them.
(laughter)
(laughs) Like, they're entitled, no shit.
You wanted to give them eight
place trophies ass hole.
(laughter)
So stupid.
(sighs) The number one thing
practical that you can get
out of this talk, go home
and start doing, is realize
that if you're not
communicating to the world,
then you're in trouble,
because attention is the asset
and whether you're producing
content or you're running
advertising, if you're not
doing one of those two things
you're actually really vulnerable.
By biggest concern is
there's a lot of people here
who are actually having a good year.
How many people here are having their best
year in their business, raise your hands.
That's phenomenal, excites
the shit out of me.
It also scares me to no end
because if you're winning
without the stuff that
I believe in, it means
that you're vulnerable.
There reason you're
seeing videos of me pop up
talkin' about Toys "R" Us or Sears,
or other thing in trouble
and now it makes me look really smart
is because seven or eight years ago
they weren't doing the things that I knew
they had to do to be successful today.
That became their vulnerability.
If you're selling a ton of homes,
or your getting more clients than ever
or you're, whatever it is,
whatever success you're having
if you're doing that without
producing a high volume
of content everyday on
Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn,
Instagram you know YouTube or a podcast,
you're immediately right
this second vulnerable.
Because somebody else is
going to and over time
they will take your audience, they will.
And so I highly recommend
that the tangible thing
that you do from this
talk is that you realize
that you have to go home and
figure out how you're gonna
communicate to the world,
I decided 18 months ago
the way I was going to
communicate to the world
was I was gonna be
documented living my life
and then post producing
that 12 hours of video
into video, audio and written word
because that's how we
all you know consume.
I mean people you know
I talked to digital.
For years people made
fun of me, they're like
Gary me yo talk about being so digital,
why do you still write books?
I'm like 'cause people read them ass hole.
(laughter)
I may not read them, but I'm not
the person I care about.
The audience is what I care about.
And so if you like to consume content
while you're walking your dog
are running in the morning,
then I'm gonna produce a podcast.
If you like to sit down
with a glass of wine or beer
and watch a video well then
I'm gonna produce video
and I'm gonna put it on
Facebook and YouTube and Roku
and anywhere else I can
upload that shit on,
because the number one
thing you should never do
is create friction for your audience.
Do you know how many of
you are misplaying it
because you've stopped
posting anywhere but
Instagram because that's where
your biggest audience is?
You become fundamentally 100%
vulnerable to a platform.
Go speak to all the people
that blew up on fuckin'
MySpace how that works out.
So, the number one thing you need to do
is deploy self-awareness
about yourself and how
you wanna communicate and
what you wanna communicate.
The really important part about this is
video is absolutely the holy Grail
but many people here don't want to
or feel uncomfortable being on video
and that is superfine.
Forcing yourself will always lose.
It is always going to be a self-awareness,
what you like the most
because the reality of trying
to be successful is super fascinating.
Everybody has the ambition
or thought process
of living a 1% life but the far majority
had no interest in
putting in the work ethic
of the 1% that is required for that life.
And that's fine, you know
another thing that's a
complete contradiction
is how many people I know
that are far happier when their business,
the amount of people I really
looked at a lot of businesses
at this point, you know,
hundreds of thousands probably
over the last 20 years 'cause
of my investing career,
there's so many people
that have a business
that makes them 200,000
a year, they wanna grow
and then when it goes to
280,000 they went from
extremely happy to miserable
on that small of a delta.
You know please please in a success world,
please understand that
success is happiness,
not net dollars in.
I literally replied to, I
have a ridiculously funny post
on Instagram right now
right like my last post
about me garage selling,
and a lot of the comments
were like literally things
like I don't get it,
why is somebody who's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
going out there and buying
things for a dollar and selling
it for 15 bucks and I literally
am in there, I'm like,
on the road here like
replying to some of you
when I'm gonna be on stage and replying
in Instagram to kids that are asking that,
I'm replying happiness, I Gary as a human
get dramatically happier
when I go to a garage sale
and buy something worth
20 bucks for a dollar,
and get the high of
discovering it and knowing
that I'm gonna pay a
dollar and sell it for 20
then I do when I land a $7
million deal for VaynerMedia.
And by the way, there's no comparison.
That's just who I am.
And that is what I'm
going to drive towards
and so please be very self
aware and also the reason
that works, the reason I was
able to be 27 and make 64,
you know because people
take shit out of context.
I just told that little
story and a bunch of you
were like yeah 'cause you
got hundreds of millions
of dollars dick.
You don't understand, I
was the same dude at 27
making 64,000 a year,
that made me happy then,
that's what it is, happiness
is so fuckin' important.
I'm so obsessed with it
right now and I hate that
success and entrepreneurship
and all this stuff
had been put on a pedestal.
Do you understand that most
people think they need to make
a million dollars a
year to be like winning?
Meanwhile in America, one
of the richest countries
in the world, $440,000
is the entry into the 1%.
We have success completely
completely misunderstood.
We have success completely misunderstood.
Let me tell you what success looks like.
When you wake up in the morning
and you're fuckin' happy.
(applause)
I believe in the internet
because of the long tail.
I don't think the internet,
look the internet does
create the Ubers and the
Snapchats and the Facebooks,
and they create these trillionaires.
Fine, what's amazing about the Internet
and where I really want to get your head
is the long tail.
How many people here work somewhere
but really wanna have their
own business or hustle?
Raise your hands.
A lot, for me the internet is for you.
For me, if I sat down with these two dudes
black shirt and the white shirt
right in this third row, and
they both raised their hands,
for me it's not about, if
I was sitting down with you
for three hours is not about coming up
with a business that's
gonna do 10 million bucks,
it's about understanding
how much money you make now
working a job, what you
spend your money on to live
and trying to figure out how quickly
you can get into a place where you
don't have to work at a job.
One more time, how many hands
work somewhere but wanna do
their own thing raise your hands.
More than half this audience.
Meanwhile let me tell
you why most of the hands
that just went up one never get there.
They buy dumb shit.
(laughter)
Do you know how many people here
literally drive cars to impress people
that they fuckin' hate?
(laughter)
People literally going in
debt or getting further
from leaving the job they don't like
to do something that'll make them happy
because they have to buy a certain car
that has a logo that impresses people
that they fuckin' despise.
(laughter)
Do you understand how fucked up that is?
Do you know how many
people here live in homes
where they don't use more than
half the rooms in the house?
Like, we are so fundamentally
in a vortex that makes
no sense, that I am
unbelievably passionate
understanding how much money you make
and what you can do to get off of it.
But the problem is again
people are doing so many things
to keep up with the Joneses
to make it look like
they're successful to
appease their parents
and a million fuckin' other
things that have nothing
to do with themselves.
And we need to change that fucking game.
(applause) Thank you.
And the Internet is the most likely thing.
The Internet is a place where you can make
$54,000 a year just talking
about peanut butter.
(laughter)
This is important guys
(laughter) this is super duper
important what I'm talkin' about.
The Internet unlike the real world,
is a place where the long tail
gets rewarded, the long tail.
The reason I'm on this
ridiculous to many people
garage sale hustle thing is
because the quickest way,
by the way 'cause I knew
I was gonna be here,
do you know how crazy it is
especially in a market
like this where eBay,
because Amazon wasn't here is
even more mature and ahead?
Do you understand how crazy it is
that if you went to the clearance aisles
of your five biggest
retailers in Australia,
bought things on clearance,
went home, relisted it
and posted on eBay that the
far majority of this audience
could make between 50
to $100,000 a year just
on doing that for nine to ten hours a day.
Meanwhile, everybody's
sitting here with the next
big app that's gonna be
the next fuckin' Uber
for lawnmowers (laughter).
The thing that has made me successful
far more than my passion or my energy
is my disproportionate practicality.
Most people want to look the part
of an entrepreneur that came
up with the next supreme
or Adidas brand or the
next Uber or Facebook.
Yet are $40,000 in debt
working a job that they hate
and literally if they went
to the five discount stores
that dominate this market
buy things on clearance
go home take a picture
with their fuckin' phone,
and upload to eBay and
then when people buy it
go to the post office and ship it,
they would be able to get out of debt
and get into a financial place.
But people don't wanna do that.
'Cause they don't want
to be judged for that
being their hustle.
Most people in this room in this world
would rather lose looking
like they're doing something
successful then win
and be judged for doing
something'that seems dorky.
(applause)
It's fuckin' facts.
And that leads me to the thing
that I'm madder the most,
which is why you are living your life
based on other people's opinions.
If I could punch every
person's mom in the face
in this audience I would (laughter).
It's scary to me how much pressure
parents put on their kids
and use them as products
to look good to the other parents
that they're spending their time on
when it is not in the best
interest of their kids happiness.
It's just a real broken system,
it's really unfortunate
and I am the byproduct
of parents that went the
other way which really
allowed me to lean into the
things I was passionate about
even though in the '90s in America
immigrant kids were supposed
to get straight A's,
if you follow me on Instagram
you saw my report card
that thing is fuckin' ugly (laughter)
that is the reason I
get to stand here today
because I had nothing, so I had adversity
because the quickest
way not to win in life
is have too much when you start.
And two, I was able to breathe.
I am here and I promise
if you really study me,
all I'm doing and it took me
a little while to realize it
is all I'm doing is I'm
trying to do to the world
what my parents did to me.
I feel such a level of
guilt and gratitude,
a mix of the two of how I had it
that all I'm trying to
do with my popularity
or my attention is create the shield
for you to point to.
Do you know how happy it makes me
how many people use my content
to show to the person they're
fighting with internally
or subconsciously to
give them the air cover
to do the thing they wanna do?
That makes me feel incredible.
It's the great gift of my life
that a lot of people use my content
to give them permission
to do the fuckin' thing
that they wanna do.
And that is what drives me
to fly across the whole world
and keep doing it that is
unbelievably fulfilling.
I'm gonna get mine.
I've news for everybody, I got mine
long before I got on stage
and started doing stuff.
I don't need to monetize my audience.
There is no fuckin' product that I'm gonna
try to make you by for the
next fuckin' 14 minutes.
(cheering)
What I'm doing, (applause) (chuckle),
what I'm doing is trying
to be happy when I fly home
in a couple days and read the emails
from people, and by the
way I get 'em every day.
Every day I get emails that start with
I was $47,000 in debt a year ago
and now I've got a business doing 300,000.
I don't know why it took
me four and a half years
to finally do what you been saying.
And that's the thing, just
so you understand why,
I love when people like
Gary, like the comments
are just so fun, Gary
V, like you suck bro.
You repeat the same shit (laughter).
I'm like 'cause it's right dick face.
(laughter)
The reason I keep repeating it
the reason I believe in it I 'cause
I know for so many of you even though
you've seen it 87 times,
this moment in real life
at this time might be the time it happens.
That's how it actually works.
This is a game of perspective.
Either you understand
what's happening or not.
Do you know how many people have defaulted
into thinking this is a terrible time?
My friends this is the greatest
time to be a human being
in the history of earth (applause).
I mean I don't know what else to tell you.
This is like math, this is not my opinion
this is what's going on with genocide
and health, life expensive,
like this is the best.
Like for all the fuckin' shit we have
with racism and sexism and a lot of terr,
we've got plenty of shit.
Meanwhile they have the black plague.
Meanwhile they had world war fuckin' two.
Meanwhile they had real shit.
And we sit around and complain
about the dumbest shit
in the world, people complain about
getting the wrong milk in
their coffee from a barista.
(laughter)
Or that you're, this is my,
your wi-fi's a little slower
than normal ass hole,
(laughter) like you're upset.
You can feel the speed is a little lower.
Or you got a few less
like than you're usually
getting on a post, like the
stuff we actually spend time
is fascinating to me.
It is a complete and
utter lack of perspective
and so I spend all my time
trying to contextualize
what's actually happening.
And what's actually
happening is the Internet
is finally mature enough
that is at such a scale
that literally every
person in this room can win
and not at the expense of
anybody else in this room,
'cause the long tail
is that huge if they're
willing to lean into
things that most people
aren't willing to lean into.
Humility, getting quiet in their head
from everybody else's
judgment, patience as fuck,
patience as fuck, nobody has
ever built anything meaningful
overnight.
People have inherited money.
You can win the lotto, it happens.
But not for the 99.9% and all of this
is available to every person here if
they're willing to figure out how
they communicate to the world.
And now the most important part.
I laugh at you you know why?
Because a lot of you commented
about this conference
today during the day.
Some of you complain that
people came up here and sold.
Right?
I am a weird fuckin' dude.
I decided to look at everybody here
who complained about people appear to sell
and I decided to audit
their social media profiles.
Their Facebook pages and Twitter accounts.
(laughter)
Lemme tell you about all
the people that complain
that people came up here
and sold (laughter).
Every fuckin' post out of
their mouth on their Facebook
is selling shit.
(laughter)
It's fuckin' funny, it's
fuckin' hypocrisy at scale.
People shitting on other
people selling, yet every
post out of their mouth
is buy this, my favorite
one person here complaining
has all, every post
is come for my free assessment (laughter).
Which is their sales pitch.
And so, I highly recommend
everybody here starts
really becoming religious about empathy.
You really wanna win in life?
Figure out what empathy
is and practice it.
And I have no idea how to teach it,
but fucking get it into your skull.
The reason I sell so well
is 'cause the only thing
I think about is the audience,
not what's in it for me,
what's in it for them.
That will always work.
The reason I have a good
organization and culture
is because I work for 900 people,
not they work for me.
The biggest mistake that
many of you will make
within an organization
is when you go from doing
to being a manager you
think you've made it
and now people work for you,
that's the beginning of you
working for them.
And so we are really in
desperate need of perspective.
And so what ya may
wanna do is not actually
strategize your Instagram
posts based on how many
followers or likes you're gonna get,
but maybe actually weirdly
maybe just one time
it would be a good idea
to think what the few
people that decided to
follow you actually get
out of you putting that picture up.
Maybe that will work?
You wanna build a fuckin' audience?
It's not gonna be bullshit
engagement groups,
or fake followers or all the other
horseshit hacks that
everybody wants to fuckin'
figure out to have the
perception of having
4,000 or 10,000 or 100,000 fans.
It's actually putting
in the work to create
a meaningful community
based on you actually
bringing them value.
How about that for a fuckin' strategy?
(cheering)
(applause)
And another thing while I'm on that,
for so many people that are complaining
that they don't have a big enough audience
how do you have the audacity
to wish for more fans
when you don't go into your own comments
when you only get 17 of
them and reply to the people
that are already part of your community?
From 2007 to 2011 when nobody
knew who the fuck I was
and Twitter was the platform of the day,
I spent every day replying
to every single tweet
that made a mention of me.
And used to go to sleep at 3
and 4 o'clock in the morning,
until I completely got
to everybody at that's
how I built my foundation.
People want the glitz and glamour,
and the caviar but they're not willing
to eat the shit, period.
If, I mean if you don't
understand how this actually
plays out, there is no fuckin' shortcut.
There's no hack, there's no
tip, there's just the work.
My favorite are the fitness
influencers on Instagram.
They figured it out in
fitness that you know
they eat well, they work out every day,
the're so disciplined
yet for their business
or their social media
following their looking for
the fuckin' shortcut.
The shit they make fun of
that people do in health,
they're doing in social and in business.
It's cliché I see it every day.
My friends please understand
what I'm about to tell you.
Social media's golden era will go away.
Just like search engine's
golden era went away,
and email's golden era went away.
Everything we're talkin' about right now
is in the prime of its career, the prime,
like an athlete or a
super model at the apex.
Over the next decade or two
it will lose its throne.
Most likely in my
opinion, to voice devices
like Alexa and Google
which are gonna steal
our attention because of
the level of convenience
it brings to our lives.
But visual's always gonna
play and it will always
have a place just like
email, not as good as it was
in 1997, but still an
outrageously effective way
to sell and market even to this day.
It's not like it's gonna
die, it's just not gonna
be as fucking awesome as it is right now.
You're sitting here, if
you're at this conference,
you're paying attention
to what I'm saying,
now my question is are you really
gonna allow me to make
fun of you in seven years
for not doing anything about it?
Because I promise you in seven years
most of my content is
gonna be shitting on 98%
of this room for not doing anything about
2017, 18, 19 and 20.
Please don't let me
shit on you (laughter).
Please.
I'm gonna go into very
hard core tactics quickly.
Yesterday in Melbourne I talked about this
and somebody started doing it on the spot,
DM'd me and has already
had a bigger return
on their business in one
day than everything they've
been doing in social for a year.
Influencer marketing
is grossly underpriced.
People don't know how to price themselves
to take a picture with
your product or service
or give you a shout out.
Some people are grossly overpriced,
some are underpriced.
But how many people here
sell a physical product,
raise your hands.
Everybody who just raised their hands,
if you're not spending 25%
of all your marketing budget
on influencers on Instagram,
you're leaving an incredible
opportunity on the table.
They will sell product for you.
How do you do it at scale?
You spend five to seven
hours a day, or have an
employee do it, and you DM
people one by one by one by one
until Instagram blocks
you and you have to wait
to start again (laughter),
and you ask them how much
it would cost for them
to take a picture with
your fuckin' physical product.
Whether that's an umbrella or a sneaker
or a tee, or a jam or whatever the hell
you sell you ask them how much it costs.
How do you figure out if
it's a good deal or bad deal?
You try, I don't know your businesses.
Made you start with 100
bucks, maybe a thousand
maybe 10,000 but you try always negotiate
it's like a garage sale always offer less
then they asked, see what
happens and then just see
what happens to your business.
You have to taste.
There's no metric, you have to learn.
Susie takes a picture with your shoe,
you sell 800 shoes that's a
really good deal for 800 bucks.
Susie takes a picture with your shoe,
you sell one shoe that was a
bad deal for a thousand bucks.
You have to get into the rhythm of doing.
So many people in this room,
I promise you when I say this room
I mean the whole fuckin' world,
everybody's talkin' about
theories and strategies
and concepts and nobody's actually doing.
Do you know how many of you here
have opinions on influencer marketing
or Instagram story adds or Facebook
but you've never run 'em?
You're pontificating.
I'm lookin' for practitioners.
I'm tryin' to figure out
who the fuck in this room
is going to be a practitioner.
Instagram story swipe up ads.
Instagram story swipe up
ads are fucking amazing.
If you have a business or
trying to accomplish something,
buy Instagram story ads.
What's even better about them is they
have the ability to have a functionality
that you can swipe up and send you
to a landing page which for a lot of you
who are salespeople not
marketers is very effective.
The reason so many of
you love Google ad words,
the reason so many of you
dislike Facebook marketing,
is 'cause you're not a
marketer you're a salesperson.
You're looking for an ROI on every
dollar you spend every time, that's sales.
That's not marketing and branding.
The reason I win is I market and brand.
I'm not lookin' for
anything in the short term.
I'm tryin' to build brand.
The reason so many of
you don't get the goals
that you're wanting is
you're looking for an ROI
right away to prove
that it works, meanwhile
every piece of clothes
being worn right now
was done by brand not by sales.
The Yankees didn't cookie you
and make you buy that hat.
They established a brand
over the last hundred years.
That's the game and
please understand today
and this afternoon are you a marketer
or a salesperson and do not be embarrassed
if you're a salesperson, I'm
a salesperson sometimes too.
I have a wine project coming and I'm gonna
sell my fuckin' arms off
in November and December.
That's fine, but I also
know that when I'm selling,
like a sneaker or a wine,
I'm losing brand because
that's the trade off.
Finding that cadence, the
reason I try to bring so much
value is I'm tryin' to
build up so many equity
that when I ask and don't
expect and I convert some
that the people that didn't
want it still stick around
because I brought them so much value.
As a matter fact even better when
you can really get great at it
you get the emails that
I get which is people
buying shit that they don't
need because they feel
guilty by all the value that I gave them.
Brand.
But most of all, most of all
Sydney please do me a favor,
please understand the moment.
Please understand that so many of you
have so many options at your fingertips,
if you actually figured out
what I'm about to say is true,
I put out over a hundred
pieces of content a day.
In video, written word,
audio, podcasts, Facebook
LinkedIn, Medium, my website, Twitter,
Instagram, Instagram
stories, Snapchat a day.
And I'm not putting out enough content
by a fuckin' mile.
I stand here today in front of you
and I confess that I am not producing
enough content even close, even close.
And I'm producing 100 pieces of content,
meaningful content, a day.
Think about how much
trouble I think you're in.
(laughter)
(applause)
Thanks Dad.
(laughter)
(applause)
Contextual content that
matters to the person
that's seeing it.
Everybody that follows you
or the ads that you spend
most of that group breaks
down into 20 to 50 different
demographic and psychographics.
42-year-old white women
that live in Sydney
making $400,000 a year is
a very different person
than a 19-year-old that lives in Brisbane
and makes eight bucks
an hour yet most people
make content for them and just put it out
and try to see what happens.
The reason my content is the same
but slightly different
based on the platform
is because the psychology of
the person who's consuming it
is very different on LinkedIn
than it is on Instagram.
Please leave this conference
and understand that you do not
make enough content and that
content is the gateway drug
to every ambition that is in your body
and that this is the golden era of the
underpriced nature of the platform.
Please become a
practitioner, please go home
and use Google and YouTube
to educate yourself
on how to run ads and how
to make content at scale
across every platform
because it is fundamentally
the quickest way to get
there and then when you make
the content make it about
the audience not about your
selfish desires, that
very simple strategy,
if you listened very
carefully for the last
minute and six seconds,
that very simple strategy
because of the long tail of
the abundance of opportunity
around whatever niche or passion you have
is 100% the way you can
win the next decade.
And I'm just devastated
that so many people
aren't taking advantage
of it out of cynicism
and being in the no business.
So many of you through your heads
are telling yourself and me right now
why that won't work for
your business or you
and it's fucked up and
you're fuckin' wrong,
so please stop doing it and please make my
30 fuckin' hour trip to
this country worthwhile.
(laughter)
(applause)
Thank you Syndey thank you so much.
(cheering)
We're gonna do Q&A now, thank you.
- [Announcer] Give him a hand Sydney,
give him a hand.
- Thank you.
(applause) Thank you.
I have no idea why the
fuck you're leaving.
The Q&A's the best part,
you better be goin'
take a shit because you
shouldn't leave (laughter).
Cool, let's do it.
- [Announcer] Alright, question
number one comes from Nigel.
- Okay.
- [Announcer] And he says
here to see Gary V live.
Question Gary, what's
more important to focus on
in building a great
business, personal brand
or business brand.
- [Gary] Nigel, they both can work, right?
Like, I work and that's
great, but Coca-Cola works.
Nike works, GE works, like both work.
I think self-awareness of
what you might be better at
is probably a better way to go about it.
Does it come more natural
for you to build brand
around yourself or around your business?
I've done both, I built a
monster brand for Wine Library,
well above its means
for the money that I had
and I built a great brand for myself.
I like them both.
The one nice thing about
building personal brand
is it transfers to other
areas if you change
the kind of business you wanna do.
A lot of people get
scared that if they're a
financial advisor now and
later they start a toy company,
that it doesn't map, but
the attention transfers.
And so both will work.
- [Announcer] Yeah, very
good, next question comes from
Leon, he said what did you
find helps you work in the dirt
without neglecting the clouds.
- Leon, the clouds never
get neglected in my
definition of clouds and
dirt because it's the reason
you do shit and it's what
you're trying to aspire to do.
For me I know the way
that I will achieve all
my goals is to get my hands
dirty a put in the work
in the dirt.
So many people are so fascinated
by, I mean there was a
kid last night who like
broke through like you
know like, like all, I mean
(laughter) the guy should
be a fuckin' like navy seal.
He broke through all the
things then he's there,
twice and I'm like
leaving last night's event
and we're talking for a few minutes,
I'm giving him some time and he goes to me
but Gary I envision myself in palaces
and bulletproof cars (laughter).
And I was like cool man, like great.
Like do you like I
could tell he was scared
to say that to me 'cause he knew I wanted
to punch him in his fuckin' dick.
(laughter)
But I said to him, like cool
mazzeltov like you do you,
I don't give a shit.
The problem is if you're daydreaming about
yachts and bottles and
massages and diamonds
and fuckin' all this shit,
then that's just what
you're doing.
You're day dreaming.
Leon, the reason I can focus on the dirt
is 'cause there's no fuckin' alternative.
Nobody wins without putting
in the fuckin' work.
(applause)
- [Announcer] Yeah, very good.
For those of you that aren't familiar
with the dirt and cloud
reference, it's actually
to his shoe, the Gary V 003,
so if you don't have 'em
you probably wanna get a pair.
Next question comes from Leon.
When did you decide to
try a new social platform
or rule it out as a fad, for
example, musical.ly or IGTV?
- Leon, that's a really good
question, Leon, for that
I basically just wait 'till
it has 20, 30, 40, 50 million,
100 million followers consistently right.
I never, like I loved when
peach came out or Vero.
When fuckin' Vero came
out, everyone DM'd me like
Gary Vero's the next big
thing, and I'm like cool,
let's wait for it to
be the next best thing.
Because I don't believe
that I need to be first
on a platform I just
think I need to be best.
I wasn't first on Instagram,
I wasn't first on Twitter.
I was first on Twitter and
YouTube that's actually,
I was early but it was still being best.
I'm never scared like you
could always come later.
A year and a half ago I had
80,000 followers on Instagram.
Like putting in the right
work got me to 4.3 million
followers, but that's even
besides the point because
that's a vanity metric,
it's like just building
an audience that gives a shit,
I wasn't first to podcasts.
Like this is a game about best.
The reason I win the best game often
and I'll say it again and I
think this will make sense
to you based on today's
day, I'm here for you.
Because if I'm here for
you I'm gonna get mine.
If you actually give a
fuck about your customer
and your audience you'll
get yours I promise.
The problem is 95% of the people aren't.
They're doing shit, do
you know how many people
are doing a job or a company right now
because they heard there's money in it?
How many people here
chasing cryptocurrency
and don't even know what
the fuck blockchain means?
(laughter) You fuckin' idiot.
(laughter)
And you're faking, by the way,
let me tell you about life.
You're fooling nobody.
Lemme tell you what actually
happens in life when
you play the part on Instagram
or you think you know
something about something and you don't.
You trick the 90% of
people that don't matter
and you lose credibility in perpetuity
with the 10% of people that run shit.
(applause)
So for all the young hustlers that think
fake it 'till you make it's gonna work,
for a minute, faking and
negativity and the wrong thing
always does quite well at
half time, it just always
loses the fuckin' game, sleep on that.
(applause)
- [Announcer] Next question,
hey I'm a polish dancer
and content creator who travels the world.
My question is, should I
speak English in my vlogs,
think global and be one
of the hundreds travel
creators, or should I
speak my native language
knowing there is a niche?
- It's a really good question,
you know, they both can work.
I'm a big believer in subtitles.
I've now been very active
in producing my content
in Arabic and Portuguese, and Mandarin,
it's really working for me.
You're gonna to get more
traction speaking English
for sure from a global standpoint, but I-
- [Male] Yes!
- What's up?
- [Male] Thank you, my question.
(laughter)
- So, you know, I think
you'll get a broader,
I don't think the fear of
everybody else's speaking
English and then you're one
of many, I don't believe
that the language is necessarily
the biggest, you know,
variable in your success or not.
I think there's a couple ways to do it.
One of the things you can do
is speak your native Polish
and have English translation
and subtitles over it.
I would go the other way, if it was me
I would go with English
and then I would transcribe
everything into subtitling into
Polish and other languages.
- [Male] Thanks a lot.
- You got I brother.
- [Announcer] Very good, give him a hand.
(applause)
Next one comes from Zack,
hey Gary I love all you do.
I was just wondering about strategies
to deal with the pressures of being caught
between loved ones for example
family and partners wanting
the majority of your
time in the hustle, the
dream and the goals.
Thanks Gary, is hustle
greater than family?
- Family is everything brother.
Hustle is not greater than family.
But here's the problem.
For one to be selfless and
bring value to their family,
they have to be happy.
So you know I'm very
passionate about this,
it's not the popular
politically correct current
conversation, but I genuinely believe
that the majority of people
need to make themselves happy
first so that they can be a great partner
and family member.
You conforming to a family that may think
a job is more stable or that
you need more relaxation
or whatever it may be
because they're not on fire
or passionate about what they do,
is always gonna lead to resentment.
And so I don't think
it's hustle over family,
I think it's yourself over family
which then allows you
to deliver for family.
(applause)
- [Announcer] Very good, next
question comes from Norman.
Was there ever a time when you
thought that you would fail,
and if so how did you overcome that?
- Norman, I think I'm gonna,
I think I can potentially
fail at any moment, that's the beauty
of being an entrepreneur.
You're only as good as your last at bat.
So there's always a sense
in the back of my mind
that I could fail.
It's why I've always really
resonated even though
I grew up a much bigger boxing fan,
and I'm still a bigger boxing fan,
there something I love
about mixed martial arts
is that everybody takes an l, right?
Like it's just like, and I
think if you're in business
for yourself, I mean, how many people here
are entrepreneurs and have been for over
five years of successfully?
Like, you know, a lot of us
know, it's lonely as fuck.
Like I woke up at 4 o'clock in the morning
this morning because there's
some shit going in my LA
office and I had to cancel
a trip to Hawaii next week
for a conference that I
really wanted to go to
'cause I have to go to LA and fix shit.
When you're an entrepreneur,
you own your shit,
you're a firefighter, you're
the last line of defense.
I always think I can fail.
It's the reason I'm great.
I think it's like a
fighter, you go in there
and you know that any
moment even if you're a much
better fighter than the other person
one punch can change the outcome
and that's what I think
entrepreneurship is.
I wake up every morning
knowing that one punch
that I didn't see coming
could change the outcome
of everything that I've been doing,
and that puts me on edge that I like.
I like being awake and focused
and most importantly I like
that level of humility.
I genuinely I promise you hear
out of every fuckin' person here,
even if you sit here and
your friend brought you
and you didn't like me
and you think I'm shit,
nobody thinks less of themselves,
nobody thinks less of
me in this room than me.
I mean that.
I am just unbelievably
not high on my own supply.
I appreciate the admiration,
I understand what's happening
with me but I promise you
if you could read my insides
on a piece of paper I
stand up here knowing
I'm not shit, and tomorrow
it can all go away
unless I continue to execute
and I play on that edge
every day and I appreciate
and I'm flattered
but I'm not fuckin' confused.
(applause)
- [Announcer] There's a big difference.
Big difference man.
Next question comes from-
- Which really fucks with
me because 99% of people
(laughter) no, really,
because 99% of people
that I see that aren't even
close to doing the shit
that I'm doing get one little headline
or have a viral day or have one person
with a blue check follow
them and they think
they're fuckin' special.
If you think you're special,
you fuckin' are finished.
I mean it's important to have confidence
but don't get delusional.
It is absolutely your vulnerability.
And let me remind everybody
under 32 in this room
you have not faced a bad
economy in your entire life.
So you not been punched in
the face in a macro way yet
so whatever you think you
are, you're playin' in a fake
fuckin' environment,
you haven't done shit,
you're in the minor leagues boy.
(laughter)
(applause)
- [Announcer] How do you
stay from being disillusioned
that way, for you?
- [Gary] It's really
simple, I genuinely wake up
and think like I suck,
nothing mattered that I did
yesterday, like I might not
be seeing some, I'm sharp,
I'm like completely
convinced that like cool,
but like I said something
recently that caught
a lot of people's attention
when I say get quiet,
I talk about get quiet from
the haters, don't listen
to anybody right?
But I think the part that
people didn't understand
is I meant the compliments too.
All this love and admiration,
I, you can't imagine
how good it feels, but
it's not penetrating
my operating system.
(applause)
- [Announcer] Really good.
Next question comes from Michelle.
Why did you choose to offer your amazing
business advice and
knowledge at the simple price
of a seminar ticket or
purchasing your book,
free Instagram posts and YouTube videos
when others are charging people huge money
for courses with the same information?
- 'Cause I'm dramatically more
talented than them Michelle.
(laughter)
(applause)
I took a business, you
know I always tell people,
I love when people try to find reasons
to not listen to me or
to tell their friend
that likes my stuff not to listen to me.
They always try to go to the fact
that I had a family business
and they make up shit
in their own head that isn't true.
Like, people like I mean
I've seen it for years,
well his dad gave him $3 million.
The business was doing $3 million bucks.
Well he had a head start,
I left at 34 years old
with no money to my name because I spent
the first 12, 13 years of my career
building my family's
business for my parents
and I left with no equity in the business.
Right, so Michelle I took a business
that was doing $3.7 million
in business and grew it
to a $60 million business in
eight years with no money.
No venture capital, no
credit lines, I just operated
like a fuckin' maniac and
built a huge business.
I think people are very
confused about VaynerMedia.
Let me tell you about corporate life.
Corporate world doesn't
believe in social media
and it doesn't give a fuck about Gary V,
the wine guy who was on Twitter.
In eights years, and really
in nine years, really seven,
'cause the first two
years I wasn't active in
VaynerMedia, in seven
years I took a business
that didn't exist selling
something to this day
that companies don't wanna
buy, and I grew it from zero
to a $150 million
revenue revenue business.
I'm a fuckin' talented
business man so I don't need
to monetize you for my wealth creation.
I do what I do here to be
the other part of my life
to get the high of, hey
listen, I love admiration
and attention and clearly
I have that trait,
but the answer to your question Michelle
is 'cause I'm fuckin' way more talented
than they are and don't need your money.
(applause)
(laughter)
- [Announcer] Next
question comes from Jaime.
I'm excited about creating
my first Twitter account
to ask Gary this question.
- That's awesome.
- [Announcer] I feel like
it's not the opinion of others
that bother me, it's my opinion of myself,
so are there any
strategies for blocking out
the negative opinion one's
self can have about themself?
- Absolutely Jamie either
your mother or your father
put that negative opinion
about yourself in your head.
Once you realize that that's true
then you stop shitting on yourself
and realize somebody else made you do that
and you start the process
of loving yourself.
(applause)
We are not born to think we suck.
It is instilled and the
insecurities or negativities
of the people around us, the end, the end.
(applause)
So if you are sleeping at
night and you're shitting
on yourself, you need to,
first of all, and by the way
this doesn't mean you
should hate your parents,
they were doing that because
that happened to them.
You need to understand
this is a very long game,
but you need to understand that you do not
have that opinion of yourself
that was instilled in you
and one of the biggest
reasons I think people need
to spend time with positivity
and consuming positivity
and spending time with positive people,
is once you get into the practice of it,
and please, I hate when
people think positivity
and optimism is delusion.
(laughter)
It's so fun, I'm with
you, like it's funny.
Like, people are like oh
you're drinking the Kool-Aid,
or this and that, that's
just negative people
tryin' to bring you down to their level.
Optimism positivity is practical.
Do you know how crazy it is
that we're still on earth?
We've had bombs, if we're so evil,
if this sucks so bad we would've been gone
a long time ago.
The human being is the most
underrated thing in the world.
The far majority of us
are unbelievably good.
It's scary actually, and so yeah Jamie
you need to understand that
that voice is not in your head.
- [Announcer] Yeah very good.
- Keep going if we have some, what's that?
(speaking off mic)
I got you brother, (laughter)
are you wearing a turtle neck?
(laughter)
Dude, you've already
won, I mean (laughter)
if you're not worried about being judged
about wearing a turtleneck
in 20 fuckin' 18,
you're fuckin' unstoppable bro (laughter).
(applause) You are fuckin' unstoppable!
Stand up! Look at this.
- [Announcer] Yeah baby.
- Turtle neck.
- [Announcer] Unroll it
all the way up, unroll it
all the way up (cheering).
- This is not a man who gives
a shit about everybody else.
(laughter)
- [Announcer] Next
question comes from Ashlyn.
Hi Gary-
- D Rock, where are you?
I need to get a turtle neck
(laughter) I need to wear
one immediately please email the team.
(laughter)
- [Announcer] Watch out Brisbane.
Next question comes from
Ashlyn, hi Gary, I haven't
started using social
media because I'm worried
that anything I add will be more rubbish
or noise that my valued customers
would just scroll past, I feel stuck.
- You know Ashlyn, like,
you have to understand
that opinions and different perspectives
and points of view are
unbelievably valuable.
Like I was, when we landed here today
I made a video but D Rock fucked it up,
but it would've been really great.
(laughter)
It's true, right D Rock?
It was corrupt, the file was
corrupt, I don't know why
but that's on him, anyway.
(laughter)
All of you missed out
on a tremendous piece of
content.
- [Announcer] It was probably
good too.
- And the basis of the
content was very simple
which is look, I have my
opinions and passions and ideas.
But I hope that everybody understands here
and ironically in the last 20 minutes
maybe for some of you you
got to see a different
part of my perspective,
I don't think my opinion
is any greater than yours.
I don't have the audacity to
think I'm right or special
regardless of my results
in the short term.
They're just mine, they're
my perspective, the end.
And so Ashlyn I really
think you should share them,
because everybody else's is the same shit
and if you actually put it out
and this is why I pushed you so hard today
to think about them not you.
Like if you really really
really put out shit for them,
it's why we all overreact
to when somebody shares
something negative about themselves
because were so not accustomed to that
and when they're doing that
it's being done for you
as much as it's been done for them,
'cause it gives you another example.
Everybody in here has something
that they've never told the
world that if they told him
they would eliminate that poison
and breathe so much easier.
The reason I love living
such a transparent world
and being filmed all the
time and having all my admins
and different people in
my passwords and DM's
and everything is it doesn't
give me a place to hide,
which is unbelievably powerful.
The reason I love privacy going away
is privacy is the shadow
that creates negativity
not the reverse.
- [Man] Woo hoo.
- I want everybody to
walk around naked, that
shit was wild, (laughter) I mean it.
- [Announcer] Just turtle necks though.
- Yeah (laughs).
- [Announcer] Last
question comes from Sam.
Sam wants to know-
- 29 teens say I'm preorder now baby!
- [Announcer] When is your album dropping?
(laughter)
When is your album dropping?
- Sam, the reason I spend
some much time with emerging
hip hop artists is 'cause it's two fold.
One, I genuinely believe
that hip hop culture
is foundational to society.
You know I really understand that
36-year-old white kids in middle America
will act on something
that happens in the hood
in Atlanta 18 months earlier,
it's just a framework.
That's interesting to
me but more importantly
there's nothing, entrepreneurship in 2003,
four, five, six
looked like this, now it's
become a sport of affluence
and students and posturing and coolness,
but hip hop is still a
grimy game of making a piece
of art and tryin' to
get people to hear it.
And the ones that always when are spitting
such truth to the current
mindset and reality
of their environment that's what I do,
that's what I just did for 50 minutes.
So I associate with it so heavy.
And the other thing is us for fun,
much like watching Uber and Snap,
I mean the first time
I went into Twitter's
office, they had six employees.
Yeah, it's just such an
amazing, like I'm literally
getting goosebumps it's just wild.
I was in the hotel room in Paris
when Garrett Camp literally
pitch the idea of Uber.
Literally I was in a hotel room in Paris
and Garrett Camp who's also
the founder of StumbleUpon,
so a man who's created unbelievably plays,
and Uber being obviously so revolutionary,
literally with a bottle of
whiskey and eight people
he says hey, wouldn't
it be cool to get a limo
if, like from just from your
phone as soon as you needed it?
And I remember thinking like,
that's stupid that's only for rich people.
So I'm not always right either.
(laughter)
But like that high of
watching the world evolve
I'm getting the same
sense for spending time
with emerging hip hop artists
because if you get to spend
time with Lil' Wayne or
Jay Z, or Drake, six years
before it happens there's
just a level of like that.
I love the shit, I love
being early in a lot of ways.
But most of all the way
they navigate the world
is far more the way I navigate the world,
at least in my head.
- [Announcer] Very good (applause)
so you came all this way
any last words you wanna
give Sydney or the folks
that came here?
- See, listen, here's where I'm at.
And you've heard me say this,
I know a lot of you resonated
with this piece of content.
There's nothing you'll
accomplish in your life
that's more miraculous than the fact
that you're a human being.
It's bonkers crazy, like it's so rare
like if you care about math the fact
that you're sitting in this place,
that your human, like you
could've been a ladybug.
(laughter)
You coulda, like, you're
a human, the most alpha
species in the world.
Like, you have one life.
How you're gonna waste that
because of other people's
opinions or your own
opinion of yourself that was
fabricated by somebody else
is something that I'm just
not willing to not talk about until I die.
And so please, please
understand you have one life.
Do something with it, for real.
And especially when we
have a moment like this
where this Internet
thing, like this is like
this will be talked about,
this will be talked about
in hundreds of years.
Like the way the Rockefellers
and the railroad stations
and like this is big, this is real big,
and you're sitting on it
and you're not squeezing
the fuck out of it on some bull shit.
So please do something with your life.
It would mean the world
to me, thank you so much.
- [Announcer] Give him a hand Sydney!
(applause) Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you Syndey.
(cheering)
Thank you guys, thank you so much.
♪ When all I really wanted
was to have some fun. ♪
- D Rock.
(applause)
Thank you guys, see ya.
♪ You're number one, when
it was just a fling now. ♪
- One last couple of
announcements, platinum people
just stay where you
are, we'll tell ya where
you need to go to get your.